every piece will be represented by an
air things device instead so let's see
how Magnus gets off I'm going to go
piece by piece I'm hoping that this is a
king and these are pawns and that this
is the bishop and hopefully Queen H6
should be made in two 2016 right yes
Carlson against karyakin has mine has
been following the world championship
the ding is wide against napoleonishi
and here he could have taken the Rook
with the queen eventually green goes
back here into D2 Queen B2 52 in F3 and
eventually the king is
running away I think should have found
this thing
this has to be uh Kasparov tupalo from
99 in RS that's a queen and this is a
queen and he played Rook T4 CD4 okay
fine
Queen C4 oh he takes an F6 yeah it's
nice
okay I need to know my classes oh my